Activision Blizzard doesn't know whether
their Esports leagues can survive and
now they've admitted as much publicly
this comes after a group of OverWatch
League teams reportedly approached
blizzard through a law firm asking for
some kind of help given the lack of
profitability so how the hell did we get
here and how bad will it actually be
all right guys before we get into the
video just a quick reminder that liking
the video if you like the video and
subscribing to the channel if you're not
already subbed really does help support
the channel cheers okay so last week
Activision Blizzard admitted publicly
that they may not be able to fix the
issues with their professional Esports
leagues I caught it because of a tweet
by Jacob Hale so Props to him for that
and also for linking directly to the
public SEC filing quote our
collaborative arrangements for our
professional Esports leagues I.E the
OverWatch league and the Call of Duty
League continue to face headwinds which
are negatively impacting the operations
and potentially the longevity of the
Leagues Under the current business model
we continue to work to address these
challenges which could result in
significant costs and such efforts may
prove unsuccessful so uh in layperson
terms it's not looking good Hale was
able to link to it because this is a
publicly filed quarterly report as
required of publicly traded companies in
the United States then at the end of the
year they issue a different filing which
is an annual report it's also very good
to have this information on a report
like this because well lying on these
things is a really bad strategy so
because this is a publicly traded
company blizzard has to eventually come
out and say listen nah we don't think
it's gonna work out or at least there's
a strong chance that it might not and
that will impact the company's finances
which is why they have to disclose it
but why don't they just change the
leagues I guess well the problem with
that is that well
people spend a lot of money to get into
the leagues as they currently are so if
you started watching Esports in say 2018
then you've always watched Esports that
included these huge franchise leagues
but there was a time before these
Leagues with million dollar buy-ins and
back then investors were worried about
the amount of risk in Esports let's take
League of Legends for example in 2016
energy bought a spot in the nalcs they
paid for players they paid for staff all
the other expenses involved and at the
end of 2016 they were relegated they
lost basically all of that and we don't
know exactly how much the spa cost but
it was almost certainly at least seven
figures now I think you could probably
argue that NRG benefited in some way
from their time in the nalcs even if
they later lost the spot and I think
there's some Merit to that but you could
see why investors might get a little bit
kg about you know investing seven plus
figures and then just losing it at the
end of the year the first to announce
their intention to reduce that
volatility was basically the OverWatch
League in 2016 at BlizzCon the league
was announced and it was going to
feature Home and Away games with teams
hosting other rival teams and then
traveling much like you'd see in
traditional Sports and at that BlizzCon
Activision Blizzard CEO Bobby codic was
seen rubbing shoulders with some big
names in sports investment including
Robert Kraft the owner of the New
England Patriots spots in the league
were franchised and according to
reporting at the time and later
interviews they cost somewhere in the 20
millions of time karak was Unapologetic
about his vision he wanted a premier
Esports League that could compete with
the biggest names in traditional Sports
this is being touted as the next NFL
compared to the Premier League of the
future what's your vision for this is
that for real
yeah that's our vision for how we're
going to celebrate and reward our
players is build a league that is like
the NFL only Global obviously the league
was never fully realized in the form
that conic described and then once the
pandemic hit everything became a lot
more complicated including the whole
idea of traveling but I want to note
something before we move on whatever
damage the pandemic did to the league I
think it's fair to say that it did a
whole bunch when you reduce the amount
of risk inherent in investing in the
league that doesn't actually monetize it
just makes it more attractive to people
who want to spend money to get into at
the end of the day you still have to
have a plan for where the revenue is
coming from other Esports leagues did
end up following Blizzard's lead we have
the League of Legends Regional leagues
many of whom franchised and then they
also launched the Call of Duty league in
2020 which had a very similar sort of
model and sure launching in January 2020
I'll give it to them that was really bad
time so how did they go about trying to
monetize these things well they tried
the whole broadcast deal thing much like
professional sports leagues do they
signed an exclusivity deal with twitch
for the first two years worth at least
90 million dollars then there was a
YouTube deal in 2020 that was reportedly
valued at 130 million over three years
but trying to send viewers to YouTube
honestly might have hurt viewership in
the long term side note here OverWatch
league is apparently still broadcasting
exclusively on YouTube even though that
deal has been completed I don't know why
that is but I do wonder if they're
trying to negotiate another deal and
frankly if they fail to do so or if they
knew that they wouldn't be able to get a
deal that would be substantial enough
maybe that's why they felt they had to
put this on the 10q finally because the
revenue from broadcast just isn't coming
in I don't know I don't have the facts
on that but just an ID what else can you
do besides a broadcast deal well you
know things like merch we're never gonna
pull the whole wagon for blizzard
especially this early on when you're
trying to build fan bases for these
teams right that kind of leaves
advertising right and advertising has
been sort of a problem for Activision
Blizzard the big issue was that blizzard
kind of became radioactive over a period
of time they had scandal after scandal
in the news alleged cultures of sexism
employee mistreatment all sorts of
things and I don't blame advertisers for
maybe
re-examining that relationship also some
of their Flagship Games like World of
Warcraft were frankly pretty bad during
this period of time I don't think that's
controversial and players in game were
literally protesting the actions of
blizzard out of game anyways I was
pretty focused on OverWatch league in
this and I want to acknowledge that and
just say that Call of Duty League kind
of face its own challenges including a
very unlucky launch date but also Warsaw
yeah I mean warzone's popularity was
seen by some as a potential threat to
the Call of Duty league but nobody paid
20 million dollars for Warzone League
they paid it for the Call of Duty League
could the CDO has a freaking choke code
where their teams like yo Isaac we
bought in 25 million dollars hey you
can't have these big tournaments anymore
because hey people are caring more about
Warzone tournaments in the CDL but we
paid 25 million dollars welcome to
business people are viewing more Warzone
that's so sorry but sorry people don't
don't want to watch the CDL anymore bro
people want to watch Warzone tournaments
that's why we had back to back to back
to back to back to back 100K tournaments
investor sponsors everything else and
that's gone now CDL teams inverdance
because the CDL team's like oh some of
our Pro players want to play this war
zone tournaments more than they want to
play CDL so how bad is it well it could
be pretty bad without going into Super
granular detail most of the
organizations and the OverWatch league
and Call of Duty League are
organizations that you already know
there are some other ownership group
that owns an Esports team that isn't
affiliated with those leagues those
organizations forked over a bunch of
money to get in maybe to both leagues
even and on top of that they've been
paying player salaries staff all the
things you have to do to run an Esports
Organization for this whole time and
well it doesn't seem like money is going
to be made hell remember how I said that
there was supposed to be home and away
games
some of these organizations
developed plans for buildings bought
land maybe even started building them
and now those plans have to be changed
scaled back or maybe even canceled
because it doesn't look like those home
or away games will be happening anytime
soon but the biggest thing for me Isn't
about the money that the investors will
lose it's what the human beings that
will be affected by this the teams have
big staffs they have rosters of players
and again support staff that do all
sorts of things these are human beings
who wanted to be part of Esports now
well who knows what's going to happen to
them if blizzard decides to kill the
league it's hard for me to tell you
exactly what would happen because I
don't have their contracts so I don't
know who's taking on what kinds of
liability or whatever I will say this
though if blizzard ever wants to run a
professional Esports League again and
honestly I'm not sure that they do they
better make a damn sure that the people
they convinced to go into business with
them that caught it convinced to buy
into this Vision they better make sure
that they are not the only ones holding
the bag because while I don't think
there's a lot of confidence in blizzard
right now to run Esports leagues if they
do this wrong if they bleed out their
business partners to the maximum
allowable extent I can pretty much
guarantee you that there will never be
that confidence ever again
are you also Roosevelt pilled are you
also Roosevelt pill well guess what
I I broke into his Mausoleum and I
resurrected him using that cromancy and
he real pissed about what's going on so
he and I were gonna have a chemical
drinks later we're gonna figure it out
you know we'll see we'll see what's up